[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est que
vous devez vous retourner, un assez grave
accident à l'avance, tout ce que nous pouvons faire,
votre médecin ou quelque chose comme ça,
jolie poupée, c'est ce que vous pensez le jour au
travail, le mal est contenu, comment pourriez-vous
ne pas me dire que vous me gardez  pour
les klaxons ce soir, euh, il sera de retour
tôt demain matin, tes
parents ne gardent-ils pas des trucs effrayants à portée de main et
gardent tout cela enfermé dans une pièce, ce
n'est bon pour personne d'y entrer, mon
père dit que tout là-dedans est
soit hanté  maudit ou il a fait une
pratique rituelle, qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
zone reste maintenant en place, les pièces de monnaie sont passées sur les
yeux des morts pour qu'il puisse prendre leurs
cellules,
qu'en est-il de la poupée qui est là-dedans et
qu'elle est dans un étui pour une raison
[Musique]
Annabelle mr.  esprits du père bacon
mme.  Martha, ok, il se passe quelque chose
à l'intérieur de ta maison et nous ne savons pas vraiment
quoi faire. Puis-
je parler à Annabelle ? Je suis désolé, tu dois
lui donner une âme, chérie.
[Musique]
toi